here is when we first met gaga what's it
like to all of a sudden look up and say
I'm the hottest act in the world I don't
think of myself that way you know it
doesn't matter if I'm number one now I
want to be number one for the next 10
years it's been nearly 10 years since
Gaga's first et interview and she didn't
just Teeter on the edge of glory she
surpassed it on her terms I don't like
fake people I like it straight up down
the mill and I'm from New York I can
smell them from a mile away
before telling 31 million albums
worldwide and making the phrase meat
dress a thing she was just a little
extra chasing her dreams in a 2001
episode of The Sopranos Gaga got her
first TV credit as girl at swimming pool
number 2 in 2005 she was served a dirty
salad on the MTV prank show boiling
points three years later and almost a
famous Gaga even made a cameo on the
hills it is like an intense cancer and
by 2016 she was a Golden Globe winning
actress for her role an American Horror
Story I never imagined any of this this
is truly magnificent now just call her
leading Lady Gaga with the release of a
star is born
[Music]
but can you believe in 2011 she told ET
acting just wasn't her thing like to act
in my videos but I I'm not an actress or
I'm a musician so I'm a musician right
now yes I see a movie and my comeback
could be like you told me you want me
but it looks you go buy a ticket
lots of people buying tickets and she
deserves everything that's coming her
way as far as the music bull don't worry
that's fill her number one her Vegas
residency enigma kicks off December the
28th at MGM's Park Theatre
[Music]
[Applause]